gilbert roger sénateur ps de
seine-saint-denis et ancien maire de
bondy bonjour merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france un bon jour sur
le territoire envoie dans des quartiers
sensibles des agressions contre les
forces de l'ordre qui augmente ses
dernières jours
à quoi est-ce dieu on a vu un un motard
donc il ya qui a heurté une portière du
véhicule de police
est-ce que c'est s'avérer véritablement
le déclencheur ou est-ce que le
confinement rajoute un petit peu aux
tensions
à quoi est-ce que c'est du tout ça je
pense que le confinement rajoute
beaucoup aux tensions actuelles
c'est extrêmement difficile pour nos
concitoyens ça l'est pour nous mêmes
mais je crois que c'est encore pire
quand on est nombreux dans un petit
appartement et parfois aussi avec des
conditions d'hygiène et de salubrité
pas extraordinaire je pense à des
logements qui mériterait de sérieuse
rénovation est ce que ça justifie
nathalie ans non mais ça peut faire
comprendre qu'il y en ait parce qu'on
constate bien que en intra famille se
développent des violences en particulier
faites aux femmes ou aux jeunes enfants
là la deuxième chose c'est beaucoup de
jeunes n'ont pas cru au corona virus et
n'ont pas cru à ce que l'on appelle les
mesures barrières et au confinement
notamment parce que il ne voyait pas la
maladie se propage et autour d'eux on
disait surtout dans les premiers temps
que seules les personnes les plus âgées
étaient des personnes à risque il faut
avoir ça aussi en tête et puis après
je pense qu'il y a peut-être des micros
phénomène d'endroits où des jeunes
volant en découdre pour excusez-moi
l'expression mais s'occuper un peu quoi
justement est ce qu'il ya une crainte
d'affrontements d'embrasement parce que
ça justifiait son vous écoutez quand
d'embrasement je souhaite que l'on sait
c'est difficile pour chacun de bien
prendre ce que l'on appelle la
température dans les quartiers
populaires mais il ya aussi de belles
initiatives beaucoup de jeunes de clubs
sportifs d'associations culturelles se
sont réunis pour aider leur prochain et
en particulier les gens les plus
gravement touchés par la crise
économique et sociale qui a entraîné eux
le confinement et la perte totale
d'activité
donc est-ce qu'elles ont gagné de belles
choses qui se passent dans nos quartiers
populaires à ce que vous craignez de
nouvelles violences la prochaine mais
comment faire pour éviter qu'elles ne se
reproduisent et comment faire je pense
que chacune chacun essaie de faire les
appels au calme nécessaire
et puis tout à l'heure dans dans environ
20 minutes
on va avoir deux en seine saint denis la
conférence hebdomadaire par téléphone
avec le préfet donc on va regarder
comment de façon collective
les élus et les représentants des
services de l'état peuvent agir
je pense aussi que le fait qu'on annonce
désormais la préparation du
déconfinement le retour à l'école donc
peut-être le retour au club sportif et
aux associations de culture
donner des perspectives intéressantes
parce que c'est vrai qu'il y à des
familles qui ont beaucoup de mal pour
elle même organiser la journée scolaire
de leurs enfants
merci merci cellulaire n'est pas en
égalité devant cette éducation loin s'en
faut et beaucoup dans les quartiers
populaires ont énormément de mal il faut
tenir compte de flap merci c'est le mot
de la fin à gilbert roger d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes sénateur ps de
seine-saint-denis ancien maire de bondy